shit happens ja das sagt man eigentlich
so wenn man ein bisschen was schief geht
aber das ist auch die unglaubliche
Reaktion der klimakleber auf eine
Fahrradfahrerin in Lebensgefahr was war
passiert ökoextremisten verursachen
durch eine klebeblockade einen Stau
mehrere Kilometer lang verzögern so die
Rettung einer Frau die kurz zuvor noch
von einem LKW überrollt wurden wirklich
unfassbar das hier ist ihre Reaktion
darauf der radikale
klimaextremistrationeller schreibt bei
Twitter über den Vorfall scheiße aber
nicht einschüchtern lassen es ist Klima
Kampf nicht klimakuscheln und shit
happens so wer ist der Mann der keine
Reue sondern nur hohen zeigt harzio
Müller klimaextremist wer Klimaschutz
verhindert schafft die grüne RAF das
sagte er in einem früheren Interview
unsere Reporter Peter hell hat Müller
konfrontiert nachgefragt warum er einen
so menschenverachtenden Tweet abgesetzt
hat warum er den Klimaschutz offenbar
über Menschenleben stellt und er er
stellt sich jetzt selbst als Opfer da
die keine Empathie für die Frau die
verletzt wurde dass sie so ein Tweet ab
ich habe meinen Tweet gelöscht und habe
mich dafür entschuldigt und würde jetzt
sagen sie können über die Frage
berichten über die eigentlich geht
natürlich
die Möglichkeit eine Stellung zu
beziehen warum sie so ein sweet
abgesetzt planen planen nicht im Kontext
der bild-zeitumstellung zu beziehen die
seit Monaten gegen die Klimabewegung
hetzt und im Endeffekt ist Ihr Anliegen
die die Legitimierung von
klimaaktivismus wenn wir eine offene
Debatte führen könnten darüber was für
gesellschaftliche Risiken mit
Großprojekten Zusammenhängen wie
Klimaschutz oder Verkehrswende oder eben
dem weiteren Treiben des fossilen
Kapitalismus im Ausbau von
gasinfrastrukturen
dann können wir diese Debatte führen
aber sie wollen keine ehrliche Debatte
führen auch würden wir gerne aber das
ich habe mich für meinen Tweet
entschuldigt der war dämlich Respekt und
Empathie los und habe für diesen Tweet
von Menschen Morddrohungen bekommen mir
wurde Vergewaltigung angedroht dann
wurde gesagt dass man meine Mutter und
mich öffentlich
totprügeln würde und
solche Tweets sind auch das Resultat
ihrer Berichterstattung daher habe ich
kein Interesse mit ihnen zu reden im
Vorfeld jetzt dieses Interview Vorfeld
haben sie auch zu radikalen Maßnahmen
aufgerufen auch zu Sabotage das heißt ja
nicht dass das ein öffentlicher Diskurs
ist oder ein konstruktiver Diskurs das
ist ja aktive Aufruf zur Gewalt
ich habe gesagt dass ich das Interview
nicht weiterführen werde weil ich sie
oder für mir die Berichterstattung der
Bild-Zeitung nicht respektiere und für
Hetze gegen klimaaktivistischen
Aktivisten verantwortlich mache die dazu
geführt hat dass mir auf Twitter
Morddrohungen geschickt das ist ja keine
Hetze dass die Menschen sich Sorgen über
Menschen wie Sie die öffentlich zur
Gewalt aufrufen oder zu Sabotage das ist
ja kein Klima Diskurs das ist ja eine
ein Gewalt Diskurs und der Gewand der
Gewalt Diskurs wird von der Bild-Zeitung
gefahren und geführt nicht von mir sie
sind die die gegen klimaaktivistinnen
hetzen gut wir rufen ja nicht zur
Sabotage auf sie sind die die gegen
klimaaktivistinnen hetzen und das ist
das Ausmaß der Dinge die ich Ihnen sagen
werde weil ihm ist kein vernünftiges
Gespräch über die wirklich wichtigen
Fragen möglich würden Sie denn ein Wort
finden zur verletzten Frau
liegt im Krankenhaus der Wagen ist nicht
ich habe gesagt zur Rettung gekommen auf
Twitter gesagt das ich mich für diesen
dämlichen Tweet entschuldige dass ich
hoffe dass der Frau besser geht und ihr
habt Angehörigen ihr wünsche ich alles
gut also am dämlichen Tweet hat man ja
auch ein paar Minuten Zeit zu überlegen
wenn man sowas absetzt warum haben sie
das nicht gemacht
dass unser großes Thema heute in diesem
Dienstag und bei uns im Studio ist jetzt
Bill tv-chefredakteur Klaus Strunz Klaus
schön dass du hier bist shit happens so
die erste Reaktion shit happens etwas
was man sagt wenn etwas so ein bisschen
schief geht was möchtest du denen
entgegen in die so reagieren auf eine
Frau die derzeit immer noch müssen wir
ganz klar sagen im Krankenhaus liegt und
dort um ihr Leben kämpft ja aus meiner
Sicht ist werden wir Zeuge eines fast
historischen Moments nämlich der an dem
offenbar wird mit wem wir es bei diesen
Klebern ist auch schon so niedliches
Wort für Extremisten mit dem wem was da
wirklich zu tun haben wir haben es zu
tun mit einer Gruppe extremer sich
radikalisierende
linker Extremisten die jetzt mit dieser
Aktion also sozusagen durch ihr
festkleben Gerät ein Menschenleben in
Gefahr oder es ist noch in Gefahr eine
neue Stufe gezündet haben und mit der
Reaktion des Mannes den wir eben
zugucken konnten fasziniert zugucken
konnten
ist eine neue Stufe ausgelöst worden
nämlich die der klammheimlichen Freude
es ist egal wenn einem einzelnen etwas
geschieht wenn es um die große Sache
geht für die wir kämpfen das ist das
zentrale Motiv jeder terroristischen
Vereinigung das ist das zentrale Motiv
von Terroristen das jetzt zum ersten Mal
in klarer Deutlichkeit zum Vorschein
kommt ich will damit nicht sagen dass
der Mann in Terrorist ist bereits aber
er bedient narrative und der nutzt
narrative aus die ganz klar und die
Erkennungszeichen von terroristischen
Vereinigungen sind das macht Sorge und
da er ja selbst schon von einer grünen
RAF fantasiert hat die er als Reaktion
auf Kritik an
klimaaktivisten sieht und man muss mich
dann immer mehr radikalisieren ist heute
der Tag wo man sich doch flächendeckend
Sorgen machen muss ob da eine grüne RAF
heranwächst ob wir es mit ihr womöglich
jetzt schon zu tun haben wenn
irgendwelche Menschen sich auf Straßen
oder sonstwo festkleben das Panel
schlägt immer nach beiden Seiten aus
wann wird hier reagiert naja also und
wir sind ja immer langsam in unsere
Reaktion das finde ich für ein
Rechtsstaat auch gar nicht so falsch
also man muss ja erstmal sozusagen der
Hintergrund jetzt ist es aber klar also
ich glaube ab jetzt kann nicht mehr
darauf reagiert werden mit so ein paar
Ermahnungen und irgendwelchen
Geldstrafen von 150 Euro und einem
dududu macht es nicht mehr ich glaube
dass heute der Tag ist an dem klar wird
dass das nicht niedliche Leute sind die
für einen berechtigtes Anliegen zu
radikalen Maßnahmen greifen sondern es
sind Radikale die diese Gesellschaft
radikal und extrem verändern wollen und
sogar den Tod von Menschen in Kauf
nehmen und an der Stelle müssen wir als
Bürgergesellschaft sagen bis dahin und
keine Sekunde weiter und das bedeutet
aus meiner Perspektive auch dass ab
sofort Schluss sein muss der
offensichtliche Aktivist
vielleicht sogar schon Vorbote von
Terrorismus den wir da gerade
konfrontiert haben er hätte sagen müssen
die Erkenntnis aus unserer Aktion heute
ist wir machen es nie wieder wir denken
uns was anderes aus wir kleben uns an
Dixi Klos oder wird Leben uns an sonst
irgendwas aber wir kleben uns nicht mehr
an Infrastruktur an Fluchtwege an
Rettungswege Straßen sind natürlich
immer auch Wege für Rettungsfahrzeuge
für Polizei für Helfer in Not das tun
wir ab heute nicht mehr das wäre eine
Erkenntnis gewesen er sagt aber nicht
etwa etwas in dieser Richtung sondern er
legt im Prinzip noch nach und und
beschimpft diejenigen die ihm das
Handwerk legen wollen das ist ja
sozusagen die nächste klare Erkennung
von Extremisten dass die Täter sind die
sich als Opfer stilisieren hier sind wir
von Bild jetzt die bösen die sozusagen
Kritik üben werden als Headset
deformiert um davon abzulenken dass er
der Extremist ist das ist sozusagen die
zweite Denkfigur die wir ganz klar
kennen aus der Extremismusforschung und
deshalb muss heute spätestens heute das
Auge des Verfassungsschutzes auf diese
Bewegung wir müssen heute mit einem
anderen Instrumentarium Vorgehen das ist
nicht einfach Nötigung wie wenn jemand
sein Auto von Einfahrt parkt und der
andere kann nicht mehr rausfahren wenn
das das Strafmaß ist sozusagen mit dem
wir weiter vorgehen verlieren über die
nächste Schlacht um unsere
gesellschaftliche Ordnung und den
Frieden ganz klare Worte von Klaus
Strunz vielen herzlichen Dank für Deinen
Besuch hier im Studio und wir werden
hier natürlich dieses Thema
weiterverfolgen werden sie auch auf dem
Laufenden halten wie es der Frau die
derzeit auf der Intensivstation liegt
geht
[Musik]